- Amandla. I heard you
were thankful to have,
this is awesome, bathroom
breaks on this set.
So was there a set you were on that
You didn't have bathroom
breaks? Who should we call?
- Okay. Yeah,
I think the origin of this
particular motif is when
I have the immense privilege
and honor to be on the set of
Lemonade.
And we were in trees a lot.
That was like a huge theme of it.
And Mains and Daya were placed
up in this like really high
tree that we had to be
basically like lifted up into.
And we were up there for hours and hours
and we really had to pee,
but we didn't want to like
stop Beyonce production,
Asking to be lifted down from the trees.
So we ended up just being there like,
holding it the whole time
and being like, Beyoncé?
- What a cool project that
would be a part of as well.
That's so cool. Can y'all
relate to anything like that?
If you were ever on like a
set and you were like, God,
I really gotta go to the bathroom,
but like I can't right now?
- I was at the Oscars and it was the,
it was the year, it was 2015.
It was when I was wearing
this really kind of
tight Chanel dress,
and, I was nominated for best actress.
And we were halfway through the show
and the show lasts a really long time.
- They're not letting it go.
They're not letting it pass over.
- But anyway, it lasts like
hours and hours and hours.
So halfway through, finally
my husband and I got up
and I said,
I'm just gonna have a
glass of wine really fast.
And I knocked it back. I
was so nervous and I'm like,
I'm gonna go now, I'm
gonna go to the bathroom.
And I got in there and I was like, I,
I can't get my dress off.
I can't get it up. I can't get it down.
I can't do anything. So I
just walked down and I said,
well, I'm gonna have to
hold it all the time.
- What?
- Yeah. Yeah. So yeah,
it wasn't until the very end
after I'd done all the press
and everything that I finally
went to the bathroom with my
manager and we took my dress off.
- Just so you know
I am totally not above like
knocking on the next toilet
be like, Hey, I don't know you,
but can you undress me so I can pee?
And then I would, and just so y'all know
if you're ever in a bathroom
with me I'm gonna ask
We need another quick break
and we'll cut that out.